members at a time of cost of living is
costing hundreds of millions of pounds
of taxpayers money through the trader
support scheme six million six million
pounds per month that's 32 million
pounds at checks at the portal rally
it's increased costs to businesses
consumers it threatens our medicine
supply chain both for humans on indeed
for Animals it's driving up the cost of
infrastructure with a tariff on stale it
excludes Northern Ireland from
benefiting from any vat reduction that
may come into place in Great Britain so
this and a cost of living crises the
protocol is the single biggest driver of
that within a Northern Ireland context
and so as people face a cost of living
crises
the secretary of state has set the call
an election so that he can see a face
to do so by the secretary of state will
be an admission of failure on his part
and the part of the UK government
because because it is there who have
promised the Northern Ireland protocol
Bill who are negotiating with the
European Union and to this day there has
been abject failure on the part of the
UK government so it'll be the secretary
of state that will own the decision to
call this election but unlike the
conservative party we're not afraid of
an election if it is called we're ready
to seek A Renewed mandate to get the
Fair Deal and a restoration of
devolution on the basis of both
unionists and nationalists supporting it
that is the solid foundation upon which
disassembly needs to be created I'll
give way I think the member for giving
away and he's absolutely right to
highlight in a course of living crisis
the huge costs associated with the
Northern Ireland protocol to date but
would he agree with me that that's a
semi-skimmed version of a protocol which
is only a date operating at 10 if we get
the full that version supported by the
alliance the shin Fein and indeed the
stlp what would the course be there our
Logistics sectors would hold to a halt
within 48 hours it's ludicrous the
member has the member has an extra
minute but can I remain members that
interventions are to be short and not
speeches in their in themselves
the the
point of order
Mr active speaker the member has just
referred to only unionist and
nationalists in this house could you
actually clarify if there are those of
us who are forced to be designated as
others also in attendance
the answer the the answer in respect of
this is that my role today is to oversee
the election of a speaker and Deputy
speakers
um that we're here under the
constitution of the Northern Ireland
assembly which sets out that role any
other questions can be referred to the
speaker
I'm glad the the member for strangford
recognizes there are unionists in this
chamber
[Music]
Mr Buckley is absolutely right what do
you have now is a very limited form of
the protocol being implemented although
the party's opposite all want the
rigorous implementation to completely
hamstring the people of Northern Ireland
the unionist population will have an
opportunity in this election to send a
clear message to the European Union
Northern Ireland is part of the United
Kingdom and we will have our place
within that Union fully respected and to
unionist voters I say this
divided unionism cannot win elections
now is the time to come together the
Democratic unionist party is being
tested we will remain strong and
Resolute so too will the unionist people
of Northern Ireland
call Naomi long
thank you Mr acting speaker I intend to
keep my remarks on this short
I think given what we've heard already
there is really little and to be said in
this debate
um we will no doubt throughout the
course of it rehearse the impact on our
Public Services the impact on our public
finances the impact on individuals lives
in terms of the cost of living crisis
and the impact on these institutions on
public confidence in them as a result of
a failure to elect a speaker here today
to be clear Mr acting speaker
with this vote today which will take
place at the end of this debate
is not a vote on who will sit in the
chair you currently occupy
no one outside this chamber and few of
us in this chamber actually occur one
way or the other who that will be
we care only that someone will occupy
that chair
in order that we can do business the
jobs that we were elected to do and
serve the public to the fullest of our
ability
the question that we will vote on
therefore at the end of this debate is
not whether we know the people of
Northern Ireland are suffering we all
know they are as a result of new
institutions here it's not whether we
know that our Public Finance finances
are in a powerless state
we all know that already and it has been
rehearsed many times
it is not about whether we know our
public services are on their knees we
all know they are on their knees and
those that are not already on their
knees are tethering on the brink
it is not whether we know
that all paths laid back to the assembly
to quote Paul given in previous
conversation
it is whether we care
about those issues
whether we care enough
to prioritize those issues over party
political interest
I think the previous speaker gave us an
insight into what their answer is going
to be
as in every other setting I'm clear what
our answer is
the people of Northern Ireland and their
needs and their interests come first
and what is in their interests is a
functioning assembly
a functioning executive sustainable
institutions and Par sharing and let's
talk about part sharing let's talk about
respect for mandate
it is ironic that a member would get up
and hold forth on those issues whilst
entirely disregarding those of us who
sit in this chamber with a mandate to be
other than unionist or nationalist
entirely disregard our right to Define
ourselves and instead through heckles
from the back benches on the one seat
wander behind me we are told what we are
through the lens of what is nothing more
than prejudice
rather than people out there who
recognize what we stand for and our
values and who put confidence in Us in
May
I will take no lectures from the dup
when it comes to issues of respect
I will take no issues when it comes no
lectures from the dup either when it
comes to issues of Reform and the
unpicking of these institutions for the
dup are hoist and a petard of their own
making in Saint Andrews had they not
changed the rules then as a demand to
come back into government because
there's always a demand before you can
come into government they would be first
minister right now
think on that
think on that Mr Speaker neither will I
take advice on the dup
as to whether or not we should have
reform I simply caution members before
they hold forth on the issues of
majoritarianism to look at the history
of their party to look at their 2011
Manifesto where they would quite happily
have had a voluntary Coalition their
2016 Manifesto where they would have had
a coalition a voluntary Coalition and
where nobody else's mandate would have
been respected are modest reforms
respect not only the dup's Mandate but
the date I will
does the member agree that the only way
forward for this place is about reform
to ensure that all mandates can be
respected and those who don't want to
turn up the work and get the job done
cannot doubt and sit in the back benches
absolutely absolutely agree to be clear
the dup have argued for a reform what we
are arguing for is a reform that
respects their mandate to be in
government
and gives them the right that we have
that the Ulster unions have and that the
sdlp have do we confer those rights on
the main parties in this chamber also to
walk away where they wish to do so but
confer the right on the public
to have an executive of their choosing
I will not take lectures either in
closing Mr Speaker when it comes to the
cost of living crisis let me just
remember remind the dup Sammy Wilson is
probably the only human being alive
still championing the Liz truss many
fiscal event reflect on that when you
try to pay your mortgages that's what I
would advise people
Doug BD
thank you Mr Speaker there's an awful
lot of anger in here today and I can
understand that but I have to say the
anger that was being shown in this floor
today is absolutely nothing compared to
the anger that is out on the streets and
the towns in The Villages of of Northern
Ireland and I guess we're all going to
feel a little bit of that anger uh in
the next
um six or seven seven weeks okay it's
gonna be fun but I'd like to start with
a little bit of good news if I can and I
would just like a big shout out to the
campaign to save the Craig oven at lakes
and Parks they've Worked six years and
finally got it overturned so that their
park in Central craigavon will now no
longer be destroyed and I just want to
shout out to them well done and the next
one we have to deal with is knock IV and
we all know our champion knock IV I also
want to take a moment as well please to
to just thank Robin Swann as our health
Minister for all he has done in the last
two years it's been exceptional with
exceptionally difficult times
um in the middle of covid and I thought
he has been been fantastic and I think
it's only right at first right
yeah of course
pepper except that Robin swan has
refused to repeatedly answer questions
on abortion services in Northern Ireland
and we refuse to answer what legal
advice he had in implementation so the
Northern Ireland office had to step in
the Border
Mercedes speaker it says in my order
paper item one is election of speaker
and Deputy speaker the debits are these
referring to this
Mr Beatty can ask you to come back to
the tenor the the central tenant of this
debate absolutely speaker I should have
said it now it's a highly modest
um but look here's a here's an
interesting thing the moment uh the the
new prime minister became the Prime
Minister the first thing he did was to
call the Welsh government and the
Scottish government leaders and to pass
on his vision for the United Kingdom
he's not rang the Northern Ireland uh
further Deputy first Minister because we
don't have one
um and he spoke spoke about the
intergovernmental relations Forum which
is the four nations coming together to
talk about the issues which affect all
nay all corners of this United Kingdom
that we're part of uh and we're not
going to be part of that
because we don't have a a government
running at this moment in town
we are being put on the windowsill of
the United Kingdom
and and and that concerns me uh as a
whole UK unionist and as an Ulster uh
unionist
and of course this is because of the
protocol and the protocol is absolutely
an issue and we have changed on that
issue from rigorous implementation to
people saying look actually there are
fundamental problems here well not
Johnny fundamental problems here and we
have to deal with those fundamental
problems that there are and we do and we
can't ignore it and we have been arguing
this case since 2019 that we need to fix
these problems
but to fix these problems
shouldn't be done at the detriment of
having stable government they can be
done at the same time they are being
done at the same time they're being done
as we speak now things have moved
conversations have changed
but it's our people who are suffering
and as we get into this place where we
have nothing and we don't have even the
basis or even the foundations of any
form of government here in Northern
Ireland because the last vestiges of it
from this place goes at midnight tonight
I am really concerned that people are
now going out of their way to try and
unpick the Belfast agreement
and the language that was being used I
have to say it is is is is is not
helping joint Authority nobody's
defining what that is it's just not
helpful it's not going to happen we know
it doesn't happen the Belfast agreement
doesn't allow for it
but we're just using it because we're
using it because we have to poke each
other in the eye that's what we do all
the time
I will always stand up and promote the
Belfast Good Friday agreement
I will always stand up to say do we need
government up and running I will always
say is isn't it better to have the
arguments in this place here
and provide for the people out there I'm
happy with that and I think most of the
people here regardless of where you sit
in this place wants to do exactly that
provide for the people out there we have
to fix the issues around the protocol
and we can do that if we come together
and we can come together if we have an
executive
we need to get back to work
we need to get back to work to support
our economy we need to get back to work
to support people's jobs we need to get
back to work to deal with the nurses pay
claims because I tell you it's going to
focus Minds in the middle of December if
our nurses are on a picket line and
we're going out asking for votes it's
going to focus our minds all of us
we need to get together to find a
solution and get the government to start
moving on the replacement for the
European social fund because people are
going to lose out because it's not there
and we're going to lose jobs
we need to get back to work
to promote for all our people
people who are suffering as we speak
and I did say this before
that all they're getting out of here
from leadership is silence except for
the argues and the rants they're going
to get today and of course I'm part of
them because I'm just as angry
we need to get back to work we need to
get back to work now we need to find a
mechanism to get back to work the
secondary State needs to listen an
election will not be good but the
party's coming together for talks of
something to try and come up with it
some sort of a deal some sort of a
compromise needs to be put in place
that's what I want
I want to get back to work
I will be back in here today I will be
back in here tomorrow the OC news party
want to serve
Matthew too
thank you Mr acting speaker uh and first
of all nominating I want to welcome the
uh the passage of the uh the culture and
language act at Westminster Patsy would
be a fine speaker and this is the most
fluent going during this chamber he
would be the perfect person in this era
in July Mr acting speaker we met to pay
tribute to David Trimble one of the key
Builders of these institutions
at that time I said that many of us had
lost the ability or the willingness to
build things and some of us simply
wanted to tear things down
three months on and sadly that hasn't
changed but while this assembly has sat
North bald and silent
people's homes have got colder
their trust in politics has fallen even
further and their lives have gotten
harder my party isn't responsible for
that mass
but I'm ashamed by it
I'm ashamed of this place
because unlike others in this chamber
I'm capable of Shame
in may we asked people to vote for us in
our parties on the basis of coming here
to represent their interests and to try
to make their lives better since then
the crisis in the cost of living has
deepened and been intensified by the
actions of the conservative government
in pursuing Kamikaze economic policies
designed to make rich people richer but
in fact making everyone poorer headline
inflation is at a 40-year high budget
through that didn't rise have risen by
17 energy costs as we all know have
multiplied gas and electricity bill
payers here a weight reductions being
applied to their bills
the prepayment people on prepayment
meters don't know when they're going to
get support and for whom home hitting
all the users which is most people in
Northern Ireland all they have is the
vegan poultry promise of 100 pounds all
of this compounded by the fact that we
have the lowest levels of disposable
income in these islands and our health
care crisis deepens by the day and our
crisis in various Public Services
deepens by the day to say as the party
opposite has done that evolved
government can do little in these
circumstances is as nihilistic as it is
untrue
there may not be Limitless resources to
make everything better
but without ministers things will
unquestionably get worse budgets will
not rise nurses and doctors will not be
recruited plans will not be made
investment will be stalled since the
previous collapse in 2017 is sometimes
cited as a justification for this
collapse let me be clear that was wrong
too it damaged our economy and it harmed
public services but two wrongs don't
make a right
one area where it is true to say that
this chamber does not have much
influence is in relation to EU UK
relations and the protocol but if we
were sitting in an assembly and there
was a functioning executive it might at
least be able to try to find common
voice on what we want from our post
brexit Arrangements
people here are not just losing faith in
politics and democracy they're losing
interest in it
what we are doing today is a farce but
it's also a tragedy it is completely
removed from the needs of real people
who are suffering
and I say to the members opposite your
constituents are suffering to another
election would be a farce and it should
not happen an election Mr acting speaker
to what
it would simply serve to polarize and
waste Millions at a time when people are
in need and public services are
collapsing it would stretch the elastic
of public confidence of public patients
Beyond Breaking Point
unionism used to say that it wanted
nationalists to make Northern Ireland
work
Mr acting speaker if only we were
allowed If Only They would do the same
the dup seems set on turning this place
into an ungoverned and ungovernable mass
that is a tragedy for everyone who lives
here
but it is a huge strategic error for
unionism
because the result will not be safe
direct rule from London which would be
untenable and unacceptable not least
from this holy discreditatory government
the result would be an inevitable
increase in the number of people
including fairly moderate ones who ask
whether the real way to make Northern
Ireland work is to seek a new North in
the new island inside Europe
I want this assembly to sit
I want to serve the people of South
Belfast and all of Northern Ireland the
sdlp wants to be a constructive
opposition to those who have been given
the right to serve in government and
ministerial office
but Mr acting speaker if we are all
forced to Simply live amid the ruins of
one party's destructive and
self-destructive urges our attention and
others
will inevitably turn to building
something new and better for all the
people of this place
to mallister
distracting speaker
how dare unionists stand up for
themselves
I dare
unionists say that they cannot operate a
system which requires them to operate a
protocol that decrees that GB is a
foreign country
how dare
unionists not accept the partitioning of
the United Kingdom
how dare
unionists say
that Colony like they won't accept
foreign laws over which they have no
control under input
and how dare unionists
ever think
of using the only leverage they have
to force change on these issues
that is the Arrogant belligerent message
that's coming across in this house
who do you unionists think you are that
you should dare to stand up for what you
believe in
and of course it's coming lightest and
clearest
from those who themselves not for one
year not for two years but for three
years
brought government to a halt in this
province until they got
through using their leverage what they
needed
but how dare unionists
think themselves
that they
should dare
to defend the Union
because this protocol is dismantling
this Union that is why why of course its
greatest cheerleaders
or Shin Finn under Little Helpers in
this house
yes
I thank the member for giving away and I
know there's many members in this house
that don't want or aren't interested in
the genuine economic concerns imposed by
the protocol but what about the
independent experts who are the House of
Lords Committee just last week said that
the supply chains have full
implementation of the protocol would
grind to a halt within 48 Hours what
about the pharmaceutical companies that
said they would have a huge problem in
the supply of medicines to Northern
Ireland are these not issues which
affect all of our people
they are but sadly most in this house
don't care they don't care that our
farming Industries facing a crisis is 51
percent of our Veterinary medicines from
come the 31st of December won't be
available they don't care at the rise in
stale prices they don't care about the
30 extra in travel costs they care only
about the precious protocol because they
see it delivering they're all Island
economy which they see as a stepping
stone I'm sure we'll have an opportunity
to hear from you later
I do want to say gently
to Mr Doug Beatty
who seems to put Faith in certain talks
these talks cannot deliver
a solution
because these talks are circumscribed by
the Mandate that the EU has given them
and that mandate is only to Tinker it is
only to make the protocol work better
whatever that means
there is no mandate which arise the
sovereignty issue to be addressed in
these talks and this sovereignty issue
is the fundamental issue about the
protocol it's about the fact that we are
subject to foreign laws that we are in a
situation where the other part of our
nation is to create to be a foreign
country and therefore we must check
their goods
those issues are incapable of being
addressed in these talks because the
parameters of these talks do not extend
to that so it is an illusion to think if
only we can have these talks and of
course it's equally delusion to think if
only we could have stormed ah no cost of
living crisis no fuel hikes no problems
in our Health Service
utter delusion and the other division is
written in the fact disassembly and this
executive of the world has no money of
themselves all of these issues depend
entirely on the generosity of the
treasury and money is coming without
disassembly on the energy crisis just as
money came on covet where from from the
treasury so it is another delusion that
feeds the eagle of some in this house
who think that if only we could get
stormed back so those talks are not
going to deliver
let me say to the Secretary of State
you can call an election Bring It On
Secretary of State I'll be there to try
and stiffen the resolve to make sure
that unionism does not roll over
voting for strength not weakness but
let's be very very clear Secretary of
State
your first priority
should not be about trying to bludgeon
unionists into submission in the
protocol your first priority Secretary
of State should be about defending the
sovereignty recovering the sovereignty
that was ill-gotten by the EU over the
very place of which you are the
Secretary of State if you're the
Secretary of State for Northern Ireland
then you should be making sure as a
conservative and unionist
that the union rules in Northern Ireland
with the member Charles remarks they're
closed please and you are failing
miserably in that challenge I finished
with this
no surrender is not just an historic
slogan it's a present day list it's a
present day necessity in opposing this
Union dismantling protocol
Jerry Carl
um thank you Mr acting speaker it was
once famously written that history
repeats itself versus tragedy then as
far as to that I would add and then the
dup because recent history has shown
that no matter how much misery they
inflict on our communities no matter
what the very real dummies caused by
their actions they continue their song
and dance about the protocol and the
reason that the EP have continued this
cycle is very simple there are focus on
the protocol is designed to develop
people
to wrap up tensions and ultimately to
shore up their own vote they believe
their grandstanding and political
brinkmanship will distract from the fact
that they feel people on all stage
during this cost of living crisis but
people aren't easily fooled the party
that initially backed the protocol is
now telling people that the north
shouldn't be treated differently from
the rest of the UK they seem
fundamentalists have no problem with the
north being a special case when it came
to the denial of abortion rates equal
marriage and minority language rates
their hypocrisy is absolutely glaring
the same hypocrisy that saw a certain
dep Minister have the call the
accusatories of creating instability
here in the north despite his own
party's refusal to govern let's remember
that it was the dep who propped up the
Tories for years and their ways economic
war on working-class people across all
these islands giving hard notes to the
wealthy on austerity to the rest it was
the dup and other parties here that
voted through the cruel welfare reforms
that are now wreaking havoc and hard hit
households it was a dep even last week
who voted with Liz trusses government
when our own party colleagues were
fleeing the sink and ship indeed acting
speaker the dep notorious are two says
of the same grubby coin when this
assembly last sat the dep assured us
they could still govern them they could
help tackle a course 11 crisis because
ministers were in place but the actions
of those ministers have given little
Comfort the countless Rock and class
people who are struggling to make ends
meet
the setting of what the EPA education
Minister did not protect substitute
teachers he found they had me pay their
wages this month and it could still be
waiting for money as we approached
Christmas there will be no Solace for
teachers who face having their already
meager wages cut for taken industrial
action in the face of Skyrocket and
inflation similarly Mr Acton speaker as
people struggle to heat their homes or
keep the lights on this winter they will
not Loop the record of the dep economy
Minister for any comfort because they'll
say no attempt to attack the obscene
profits of energy companies operating
here who are raking it in while people
suffer but the spirit always Calamity Mr
Speaker people still have some Hope just
this morning I spoke with housing
executive maintenance workers acting
speaker who've been on the picket line
for 12 weeks now and have just announced
a further four-week strike action the
economy Minister here voted against the
trade Union bill which would have
afforded those workers greater legal
protection in this dispute and many are
worried about the effects being left in
the Lurch they put themselves at risk
during the pandemic maintaining people's
homes and yet they're being offered an
insulting 1.5 7 pay offer and has been
described as a raise when in fact it's
an actual cut one in three of these
workers around disgracefully on food
banks and many are paid just 6p above
the minimum wage despite the Fatal work
that they do and ahead of this session I
met on the small and they requested I
personally asked Shinn Fein Community
minister to intervene in this dispute
and ensure these workers get a proper
pay raise the money is there and they
should be paid what they are worth a lot
more than what's currently being offered
I would make a similar appeal to the
outgoing an Annie incoming Health
minister we cannot endorse health
workers getting the real terms pay cut
health workers who are preparing for
strike action in the near future
possibly weeks ahead and there are more
disputes to come Royal Mail workers out
and strike BT open reach workers right
on strike Council workers uh not just
for themselves but for everybody who
rely on those services and who deserve
much much better than what's being
currently offered Mr active speaker we
must be clear that today's setting is
ultimately about the intransigence of
the dup and I would urge him to stop
playing with people's lives and get back
in the government however make no
mistake about it we know a restored
executive won't be the Silver Bullet but
some may suggest we know that previous
Executives refused the act in the face
of a course to live in crisis under
previous economic agenda did nothing to
uplift our communities so I have faith
frankly and politicians not to deliver
without a fate but have every faith and
workers in our communities and an
ordinary people's ability to keep up
their pressure and deliver real change
so we'll actually run up I'll be
returning to pick a Lanes in the coming
days because openly that's where real
change in our society happens on the
streets and communities outside
workplaces and people taking action
thank you
um
foreign
foreign
nerve as much and on our galter axilla
culture attack or cocam lanakila akilaru
Augustine
Erna Jeffrey actor adren and H bug as
few ayanuttov
egg burger right
Allah
foreign
foreign
foreign
Michael
foreign
foreign
London
Realtors
foreign
Gordon lions
thank you Mr acting as speaker and let's
be clear this is not a serious attempt
to elect a speaker today it's not even
an attempt to have a debate about how we
can best help those that are in need
it's not even a debate or how about how
we can sort out the problems that's
preventing political stability
and the inability to form an executive
rather this is the Campion launch from
the other parties opposite ahead of this
election this is nothing more than a
stunt
everyone here today knows that there
will be no speaker elected that the
renew first and Deputy first minister or
other ministers appointed and we know
why because the evolution here in the
assembly and then the executive can only
take place whenever it is on a firm
foundation and that Foundation has been
shot to Pieces by the Northern Ireland
protocol
it's disrupted Northern Ireland's place
within the United Kingdom it's created
an economic barrier and it's led to
Constitution constitutional change
without cross-community consent
we do not have political stability in
Northern Ireland and that is as a result
of the protocol and to those that
disagree
imagine just for a second
if there were checks control posts
charges and bureaucracy between Northern
Ireland and the Republic of Ireland
imagine if those were in place and
nationalist ministers were forced to
implement those changes that would not
be acceptable to anyone and that would
not be a firm foundation on which we can
build a political stability we have
heard so much over the last number of
months about the need to protect the
Belfast agreement and that the protocol
is in some way a solution to that and
that it protects it of course it doesn't
it blows it to pieces
and I think it's become apparent
over the last number of days and weeks
in particular that for many of the
parties opposite they only care about
the Belfast agreement when it suits them
because we have the sdlp and Chin Fein
who are now calling for joint Authority
and Joint Authority is clearly a breach
of the Belfast agreement and we have the
alliance party
there are now one thing to exclude
unionists from government here in at
Northern Ireland and of course of course
they're disagreeing and of course of
course they are ruling their eyes well
look now we have got news for you we're
not we're not going to sit down and shut
up we're going to be listened to
because unionists have legitimate
concerns it'll not be a point of order
uh Mr acting speaker
respect um Mr acting speaker I'll take
your advice on points of order I'm not
the member um setting opposite
two points of order Mr Speaker if I may
on the first point of order on the first
point of order
is it in order for a member to directly
address another member in this chamber
as opposed to making their remarks
through the chair and on a second point
of order is it in order for a member to
stand up in this chamber
and completely and deliberately and
maliciously misrepresent The Possession
which has just been set out clearly by
another member in an attempt to
undermine their integrity
members as I've indicated before my
responsibility is limited to overseeing
the election of the speaker points of
order in relation to any other matters
need to be referred to the speaker
however the previous speaker has always
indicated to members that they should
use respect in this chamber and that
remarks should be referred through the
speaker and not directly to members in
the chamber sir
Mr Speaker I'm more than happy to direct
my remarks through you so I'll say it
again we're not going to sit down and
shut up because we have legitimate
concerns and those concerns are going to
be listened to because it is it has
always been the case that Devolution has
worked best when we have that buy-in
when we have that consent from unionists
from Nationals and yes from others as
well I acknowledge that but that is when
it has worked at best I'll give way to
Mr Brett thank the member for giving way
and I know when you were speaking there
the members on the alliance party ruled
in their eyes or could you remind the
house Mr Lyons how many times the
alliance party recalled this house when
Shin fee had brought it down for three
years could you remind the house how
many times Alliance tried to exclude
Shin Fein from government unionists will
not sit down and be quiet and we're
going to have ourselves
not only did they not recall the
assembly not only did they call for the
and not call for the exclusion of
sinfian when there was a recall debate
they didn't even turn up
um so I think that shows you where their
priorities lie but we do best here when
we're working together when we have a
firm foundation on which to build stable
Devolution and we do not have that solid
foundation right now but I hope that we
will but that is where the barrier is
coming from let me make uh one more
Point uh before I finish
and that is
um there's a lot of cynicism in politics
these days and it's understandable why
but my party went into the last election
on a very clear Manifesto and very clear
pledges we said that we would not return
to government here unless those issues
with the protocol were dealt with and
dealt with once and for all and Mr
acting speaker I simply say at this we
made a promise and we're going to keep
it
thank you Mr acting speaker
I Rise to confirm my support for the
nomination of a speaker today
and in the context we find ourselves in
here today I would support either or
indeed any nomination for a speaker
which would bring us closer to seeing an
executive formed and enable us to get on
with the job as we were elected to do
as a newly elected MLA this is very far
from the position I wanted to be in
making my first contribution in this
place and what is nothing much more than
a Last Chance Saloon staring at the
potential collapse of these institutions
and they've been held to Ransom by
simply one party since May's election
but here we are
and we all sat on this chamber back in
back in May most of us ready to get to
work on behalf of our constituents
but then observed the spectacle of the
dup members here refusing to elect the
speaker on preventing any business from
taking place in this assembly
and that refusal has left Northern
Ireland utterly rudderless without a
budget
without discriminate of ministers or
their departments with unspent funds
held in limbo without any Democratic
accountability in Northern Ireland
and now even the caretaker ministers
will be vacating their posts and leaving
Northern Ireland under the direction of
a Tory government in utter chaos
and we will be under the direction I
will not give away as no other members
seem to have given the courtesy to our
party and our contributions so I think
we're going to be looking at unelected
civil servants providing the only
leadership in Northern Ireland in the
coming weeks
on all this way we Face a cost of living
emergency and huge pressures on our
public finances and look those
challenges and pressures have been set
out again and again since May we have
all received the emails from the doctors
and nurses from our business Community
we have all met with our constituents
sadly in our food banks and community
centers hearing about just how much
pressure our communities are under at
the moment
but it seems that for one party in this
place those messages are simply not
getting through
our health services and crisis are
wearing lists are spiraling and
strategies to help deliver change on
issues such as cancer services and
mental health strategy unfunded and
Gathering dust without an executive
we have Hospital depart emergency
departments unable to meet demand in the
summer let alone with the winter
approaching new executive pay policy set
leaving Key workers in limbo over wage
increases as inflation rise yes I'll
give way um but the member agree with me
that it is utterly delusional of the dup
not to realize that their stunt is going
to have a long-term impact on the 38 000
children who are languishing on wearing
this at present for um Healthcare and
intervention
members and extra minutes
yes I absolutely agree and I think
anybody who heard the contributions from
the parent this morning couldn't fail to
be affected by by that crisis affecting
pediatric waiting lists it's another
issue to be added to the list of
pressures facing this place
and essentially we have departments with
no budget spending at risk to keep
Public Services functioning and we have
a cost of living crisis receiving
essentially no local response from this
place we are left entirely at the mercy
of A Dysfunctional Tory government who
seem to think that offering our people
here a paltry 100 pounds towards their
oil bill is a sufficient intervention to
help people here while the dup say that
we just need Westminster that's all
that's required to deal with the crisis
and all this deadlock this abject
failure to provide stable government at
a time of Crisis is precipitated by warm
party's protest over the protocol about
which this place can do nothing we could
keep this assembly and suspension
indefinitely and what not one line of
the protocol would be altered we all
know if we are being honest that the
only outcome that will resolve any of
the issues with the protocol will arise
from negotiations between the UK
government and the EU we need to get on
with our jobs we're not here to
renegotiate international trade treaties
were here to govern the people of
Northern Ireland and provide leadership
and we need to get on with that job and
there is anger and frustration in this
chamber event quite right we've heard
the dup refer earlier to their party
being treated with contempt in my view
it is the people of Northern Ireland who
are being treated with contempt we know
that an executive being reformed is not
a magic wand it will not make our
problems go away but I for one got
elected to try and do something not to
stand on the sidelines wringing my hands
and protesting over an issue that we can
do nothing to change in this place
so I sincerely hope that we can do the
right thing today
don't believe that we will I think that
there's one party who is going to
continue to stand in the way of progress
but we urgently need the faith restored
in these institutions and in the
Democratic process in this place thank
you
Steve Aiken
much indeed and thank you very much
indeed Mr acting speaker for controlling
this rather unruly event I think as we
go through the people of Northern
Ireland will be looking at this today
and many of them will be looking and
saying what are they doing
what is happening
because here we are squabbling
back and forth
when we do have a crisis
we have a crisis in our health care
System we have a crisis for a welfare
system we have an energy crisis
all these things are impacting on us
and yet we're squabbling and taking
lumps out of each other
we have to ask ourselves what are we
really doing
we are supposed to be representing the
people of Northern Ireland we're
supposed to be representing our
constituents
Mike Nesbitt back in 2016 when he asked
me to come and stand to be an MLA
I did because I wanted to make Northern
Ireland a much better place
I wanted a place where everybody could
be working together for the good benefit
of all of our people
since that time
I think of the six years that we've been
in and out of here four of those years
have been completely nougatry and
pointless because absolutely nothing's
happened
we have had three years
when the party opposite Shin fee and
held the place down
we have had koson coming up and we will
be high long I do not know that this
assembly will be down
let's be honest
this might be the last time that any of
us will be speaking in this assembly it
will be a long time indeed before this
assembly comes back I believe
there is a real issue with the protocol
and pretending time and time again that
you could ignore unionist concerns about
the protocol does not work
it has to be dealt with
and if we aren't complaining about it
who is standing up to try and make that
happen
I do not say that because I believe in
what the dup is doing is right but I can
speak for all unionists who have real
concerns about the protocol and it must
be sorted
and it will only be sorted when people
start listening to the real concerns of
the people of Northern Ireland that have
that not just unionists but all people
we have to do that
to the Secretary of State
I found it absolutely incredulous that
he's going out to spend about 6.5
million pounds more of public money on
an election quite frankly that people in
Northern Ireland don't want
the thing I'm even more incredulous
about but I shouldn't be surprised that
bearing in mind his own government has
wasted 35 billion pounds in the last
three or four weeks by complete anatnus
there is a lack of vision
there is a lack of understanding
but to hear people say that one of the
solutions is likely to be some form of
joint Authority
I find that absolutely again incredible
and people trying to score points and
raise the tensions right at this present
moment time does not work
the people of Northern Ireland are angry
you'll detect from my tone that I'm not
exactly happy with what's happening here
either
because we've got a job to do and we
should be doing that job
at no not at the moment
I think the real issues we have is to
make sure we restore Trust
in the institutions and in democracy
we have to restore Trust
we have to be back
so regardless of what happens and
whether we do have an election or not
and if we do have an election when we
come back here
can we not commit ourselves not to more
and more polarization
more and more water battery
why can't we do something about trying
to make Northern Ireland work and work
effectively
because that Mr acting speaker is what
we need to do and just to finally say
that is the reason why I think Mike
Nesbitt is the person to be the speaker
in this assembly I want to see him take
his vision and move that for all of us
to where we need to go
Mr Deputy speaker I think I'm probably
the only person who hasn't used my
entire allocation maybe somebody else
can make more sense of this place
because I can't anymore thank you
Canada McLaughlin
I got involved in politics for very
simple reasons to stand up for the city
that I love and its people to help bring
jobs and Investments to a place starved
of both
to break down barriers for everybody on
our Island especially women denied a
voice for so long
I'm sure that every single member of
this assembly had their own reasons it
might have been to improve our schools
get more people seen in our hospitals
tackle sectarianism or to end divisions
between our people
what I do believe however is that none
of us got involved in politics to hold
our society to Ransom
or to force the vulnerable to pay the
price of our political dysfunction by
refusing to select a speaker today
yet that is the shameful situation in
which we find ourselves today because of
this obscene boycott of power sharing
because Jeffrey Donaldson a man who will
not even come here to sit in the seat to
which he was elected is too busy
listening more to we Jimmy Brayson than
the majority of the people in Northern
Ireland the truth is that one party
refuses to accept the verdict of the
electorate just six months ago that is
why the rest of us cannot elect a
speaker today to do our full jobs
right now yes we can give out vouchers
for food banks but we can't tackle the
reasons that people need to go to them
we can raise cases with the health
trusts but we can't bring down our
weakness we can ask questions to
ministers but we can't hold them
accountable for their answers
no an executive won't solve all our
problems but it has the power to set our
priorities and it is the very very least
that people should expect of us
I can't meet my responsibilities to my
constituency without it and neither can
any of you
and when you ask people in Derry about
the current paralysis it's hard to
adequately convey their frustration
they're angry that our politics isn't
working it's forcing more of our young
people to leave and they're sick to the
back teeth of the division that is
holding us back but they don't want pity
they just want Representatives who will
be on their side who will speak up to
their needs who will work with each
other and for each other and to get
something done to bring the jobs the
opportunity that is owed to your city
they want to introduce child care that
doesn't cost the Earth but gives their
children the best start in life they
want to fund services like Northerns
that can finally deal with addiction and
the crisis that is plagued in our people
to finally deliver a university of
science that was promised that's the
very least that the people of dairy
deserve and it makes me Furious that it
has been denied next week we may be well
asking for votes again asking for people
to put us in a job when those who should
be helping to make this place work
aren't doing theirs to the dup I ask you
to reflect carefully on your election
pitch on those doors and the weeks ahead
before you vote on whether to select a
speaker today
will you be telling people freezing
pensioners that you will continue to do
nothing to heat their homes will you
tell people who can't make ends meet in
their jobs that you will continue to
boycott yours
will it be to tell people languishing on
waiting lists that you will continue to
let their weights get longer Mr Speaker
next year we will be celebrating the
25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement
it wasn't then and it isn't now a
document that guaranteed Peace On This
Island
but it was a commitment to Future
Generations that a different way forward
was possible and it was achievable
that we could leave the painful memories
of the past behind and look forward to
your future
but it is only ever going to be possible
possible if we put the hard yards in to
make peace work because this place only
works when you work for it
at this moment of Crisis we should be
fulfilling that commitment by coming
together to show the people of the north
and there is a reason across our history
and that can make their lives better Mr
action speaker that is why I'm in
politics and that is why the sdlp will
continue to work for and to fight for
because this place is worth fighting for
thank you Mr Speaker
Claire sugden
um thank you Mr acting uh speaker I Rise
to support the election of the speaker I
have no difficulty whatsoever supporting
Patsy mcgloan or indeed Mike nurse but I
think equally both will do a great job
if anything I would probably lean more
towards Patsy McGlone because I think
given his service given his sense of
community I think that's exactly what
this this assembly needs
um
I understand the issue but I really
don't understand the approach I will say
that from the outset of the protocol I
was quite prepared to see the
opportunities that came with that but as
it stands I cannot support the protocol
because within days weeks of the
protocol coming into effect I can say
wholeheartedly and genuinely that I was
contacted by Farms by businesses by
people that are going to be affected by
the protocol and I do know that the
protocol is giving benefit to some
businesses but it tends to be large
businesses and we have to remember that
in Northern Ireland we're a small medium
enterprise economy the issues that are
that are most being affected by the
protocol are coming from those
businesses if we pull the Rock from
beneath those we're pulling the rug from
beneath our entire economy
I was speaking to the Ulster Farmers
Union last week and they outlined the
issues that the protocol is continuing
to have
Mr acting speaker it does disappoint me
that this has become a unionist and
nationalist issue because I can assure
you my issues with the protocol are not
constitutional my issues are trade issue
issues and the issues that are affecting
my constituents it saddens me that
people are no longer coming forward
because they see this as a green and
orange issue we can't truly have the
debate on this issue unless we outline
the issues and certainly I would appeal
to All in This House to listen stop
talking and listen
it needs to be fixed it can be fixed and
I truly believe it will be fixed indeed
in recent weeks the Northern Ireland
officer Secretary of State the minister
of state has talked about the momentum
that is building around talks and I look
forward to that which is why it is
disappointing that the secretary States
so fit to implement the law
what I would also say to the Secretary
of State he will have to change the law
next week because we're coming to a
cliff Edge at one minute past midnight
tomorrow when ministers will vacate
their offices and normally during a
period of perda we would have care
taking ministers in place to to enact
those decisions that that matter that
enable the Departments to work on a
day-to-day basis we don't have that from
tomorrow so the secretary of state will
have to legislip so I think there is
hypocrisy in something that they
themselves had set a precedent on before
I think fixing the protocol however
doesn't need to happen in the absence of
an assembly and I would genuinely appeal
to the Democratic unionist party to
demonstrate that you do care about the
issues and I know you do because you're
a constituent submit questions as much
as I do
and do what you did in January 2023 when
you withdrew your first Minister but
allowed this assembly to function
demonstrate that you are willing to work
towards actually fixing the issues that
we are capable and responsible for
fixing and maybe that is an olive branch
to the Secretary of State to maybe take
some action and recognize that you will
work if you're given the chance to those
who say that this assembling this
executive is not capable of anything yes
we are this day week I spoke at a cost
of living crisis event and I can
wholeheartedly say to you that every
week in my office a constituent cries to
me because they can't get a house they
can't put food on their table and they
can't hit their homes we are only going
to see the worst of that and what can we
do it's more than money we can insulate
homes we could give free School meals to
every family in Northern Ireland to take
that pressure off we could defer rates
there is so much that this assembly
could do so please don't tell people on
the doorsteps and the next number of
weeks that we can do nothing because if
you are going to say that then what's
this place about it's certainly not
about the issues that you say this
morning I attended a community Transport
meeting community Transport he checks
our elderly out of our homes where our
Public Services failed and certainly I
would even appeal to the minister for
infrastructure in his next few hours if
he could look at trying to fund that
because community Transport is picking
up the pieces of the Community Ambulance
Service the ambulance service who is um
who can't even take people to hospital
and they're wearing ours outside of it
those are the issues that matter to
people and those are the issues that I
hope the Electoral will ask you about on
the doorsteps so please do what you can
there's not much time left but I would
appeal to anyone to take responsibility
for the power you hold if those are my
last words as an MLA they will Echo the
first words I had in my making speech
thank you
Mr acting speaker it is abundantly clear
that today's debate will do nothing to
fix the political situation that we find
ourselves in there is scant
acknowledgment for the concerns of
unionism in relation to the protocol and
little regard for facts on the
increasing costs of living and this
assembly's ability to deal with it so
the outset of my remarks let me be clear
I want to see the evolution restored I
believe that a stable prosperous
Northern Ireland with a properly
functioning executive and assembly is
good for all of us
and everyone feels the cost of living
pressures I dare say everyone in this
chamber cares deeply about our Health
Service our schools and our economy
but we must be real about this
assembly's ability to deal with it just
recently the Finance Minister told us
that the potential overspend in the
Northern Ireland budget was 660 million
pounds
and in a response to a question that I
received an answer from the education
Minister this morning she indicates that
there is a resource pressure in
education of 530 million and this
includes funding for children the
special educational needs School holiday
food payments increased energy costs and
the engage program
it is time to be honest and straight
talking about what this place can or
cannot do about some of these issues it
is
on the point of order Mr Akron speaker
is it in order can you advise for
members who don't want this assembly to
sit and don't want ministers to take
office to list pressures on public
services from ministerial answers which
there is no way of being dealt with
because they refuse to allow this place
to set is that an order
uh the the the member the member has
made his point as I've said and we'll
repeat uh hopefully not too many more
times in this chamber today the purpose
of this meeting for me is the election
of a speaker and Deputy speakers
it's always amazing Mr acting speaker
that when people don't want to
acknowledge or hear the truth they get
bogus points of order
um that are are there absolutely
shameful it is clear that the finances
required to deal with the cost of living
crisis will come from our national
government in Westminster and it is
there that we are working and taking our
seats to make sure that there is funding
for Energy payments for families in
Northern Ireland meanwhile the protocol
is costing consumers and businesses
every day
in the first six months of this year
the Traders support scheme designed to
support businesses with the bureaucracy
and paperwork of the protocol has caused
the taxpayer 63 million pounds that's
2.6 million pounds every week with the
bureaucracy of the protocol the protocol
means that Northern Ireland citizens
cannot benefit from uk-wide tax changes
since we are tied to EU veterans
Mr acting speaker we have to face the
fact that it's difficult to fix our
Health Service when the health Minister
says that the protocol is putting our
supply of medicine at risk and adds
additional cost to those medicines it's
difficult to build new schools and
hospitals when the protocol adds 25
percent to the cost of Steel when that
steel comes from our own UK internal
Market
and it's difficult to help with the cost
of living when the protocol adds 30
percent to transport costs for household
goods
most profoundly of all the protocol has
caused a crisis for our political
institutions
the Northern Ireland protocol has
subjugated article 6 of the act of Union
and has trashed Democratic Norms in this
part of the United Kingdom
the principle of consent is conceived by
the Belfast agreement has been ignored
for some in this chamber today it's like
a pick and mix
take it when you want it but ignore it
when you don't
unionism does not consent to the
protocol
we will not be bullied and our mandate
will not be ignored and in any election
we will take our case to the people and
renew our Mandate of opposition to the
protocol
so in finishing Mr acting speaker
there's a very clear message to the
Secretary of State the minister of state
and indeed the European Union
and that message is get on with it
the government published its command
paper on the protocol in July 2021
it has had almost 18 months to resolve
the issue the Secretary of State needs
to apply some urgency to the matter with
the member giveaway yes of course I
thank the member for giving way I hear
some laughter across the house but would
the member agree with me that when the
dup went back into government in 2020
on the condition and new decade new
approach that Northern Ireland's place
would be fully restored as an integral
part of this United Kingdom and we in
government sought to negotiate the worst
parts of the protocol that instead of
support around this house we were
undermined by every single other party
facing us here signing up not to help
get those changes but to rigorous
implementation undermining those
negotiations at a critical time not just
for a week not just for intervention
another statement
yeah
um can I thank my colleague for her
intervention and of course we all know
that the regular symptom implementers
went off down to Dublin in the middle of
a covert crisis ensure that the protocol
would be implemented
so Mr Speaker if I can return to my
point the government published its
command paper on the program
and I'll finish him shortly 2021
it has had 18 months to resolve the
issue it is time to deal with a protocol
that disrupts the United Kingdom's
internal Market that leaves this part of
the United Kingdom subject to the laws
of a foreign political entity and
subjugates the act of Union
Donny Donnelly
thank you Mr acting speaker
until this year my main job was as a
nurse working in the Ulster Hospital
like many first-time mlas I left my
career to come and work here
but since the election six months ago
I've been prevented from doing what I
was sent here to do
I haven't been able to take a part in
debate some important issues in this
chamber
or attend committee meetings to
scrutinize the work of our ministers or
departments no one has
over the last six months however I have
met with many people in groups who have
strongly expressed their wish that this
assembly is up and delivering for
everyone in Northern Ireland as soon as
possible
members from most parties attended the
crushed by the cost of living event a
few weeks ago in this building organized
by Dr Kira Fitzpatrick which highlighted
the huge strain that the increases in
the cost of living are put on many
households and families across Northern
Ireland
the speakers made a desperate plea for
Urgent action to be taken to help to
support people struggling to heat their
homes and feed their families at this
time
one of the speakers consultant
pediatrician Dr Julianne Manny told us
that she was very concerned about what
this Wonder would bring for those being
hardest hit
one of the risk factors for sudden
Unexpected death and infancy is
hypothermia pediatricians are very
concerned about fuel poverty and that
infants will be called as many people
will struggle to heat their homes
they are very concerned that infants
might die this winter of sudden
Unexpected death due to hypothermia
in my opinion this should be reason
enough to reform the executive
here or local food bank in Lauren has
seen requests for assistance increased
by 111 percent since this time last year
and they're seeing more requests from
families with children
some people have even been requesting
emergency food handouts that can be
eaten called because they can't afford
the energy to cook it
we had a presentation here a couple of
weeks ago from some Community groups who
Provide support to people with learning
disabilities and mental health
conditions to get them into and to
continue unemployment they rely on the
European social fund and this is due to
end early next year
with no other funding identified to
replace it
without urgent intervention many of
these vital services will cease to exist
for 17 000 people who rely on them and
the potential loss of 1 700 jobs from
the workers who support them
agree with me that
all the more serious given the pressures
on public finances and the fact that
many of those Community involuntary
organizations are doing jobs that would
otherwise be have to be done by
departments who can't afford to do it
there's an extra minute
absolutely I would completely agree with
that and they had a huge value to the
amount of work that is done here in
Northern land
and as was highlighted at this event a
couple of weeks ago for these
organizations time is running out and
even more so now
I've also heard from many groups
representing people suffering from
medical conditions that need action
plans to be progressed to improve
treatment for people here in Northern
Ireland
there's a group of concert patients who
can't get scans that are available in GB
because of the multi-year because of the
lack of a multi-year budget to fund the
implementation of the cancer strategy it
would appear that there is no Health
Care Border in the irisc
last week along with other local mlas I
met representatives and Charities of
over 100 businesses in Lauren that were
struggling with the increased energy
bills and other pressures some so much
that they fear they may not be able to
keep going for much longer they were
very clear that we should do all we can
to re reform the assembly to support
them through this crisis
people are spending years suffering on
waiting lists whether eyesight or
Mobility deteriorates waiting on routine
operations sometimes in constant pain
ambulances are stacked up outside or
hospitals unable to offload sick
patients because there are no spaces in
any departments and no beds available in
The Wider Hospital
or Health Service is operating under
extreme pressure and we aren't even in
the winter months yet
Mr acting speaker we are in a crisis
people are unable to meet their needs
and provide for their families otherwise
solid businesses are going to the wall
or Health Service is facing many serious
challenges things are getting harder and
harder for many of the people we
represent and we are failing them
whatever issues the parties have they
should be able to come here and work
with other elected members to do what we
can to support people in hardship
Jeffrey Donaldson leader of the dup said
in 2019 it is wrong to Blackmail an
entire community and say that you cannot
have a government until we get our way
yet here we are
Mr acting speaker it is wrong that we
have a system that allows people in
Northern Ireland to be used as leverage
in a political dispute
I got involved in politics to try to
make this place better for everyone
it's going the other way
as I said earlier my background is in
nursing and I'd like to share this
observation if one nurse refuses to be
involved in the care of a sick patient
that nurse's professionalism and ability
to do the job would very quickly be
called into question
they would fear stiff restrictions on
the practice and could ultimately be
psyched and struck off for not doing
their job
if that nurse were to prevent other
nurses from attending the patient the
consequences could be even more severe
thankfully most nurses would consider it
unimaginable that a nurse would refuse
to help a sick patient
in closing we need to help people in
need
we need to hand run some politics we
need a reform system that can be relied
on to deliver for people whatever the
political situation is and we need to be
able to work together for the common
good
I support this motion thank you
David Brooks
thank you Mr acting speaker uh I
understand this is not considered a made
in speech in terms of convention
um but it's nevertheless an honor to
stand for the first time in the chamber
and speak as one of the deep dep members
for East Belfast
I can tell you when I went on the
doorsteps in April May I spent
considerable time talking with sections
about the matter the matters that
mattered most to them and their families
no one in this place is naive or
ambivalent towards the pressures that
are being faced by families all of us in
our offices will work Dan daily with
constituents needing help and assistance
and we'll do what we can to help them
for the last six months the dep ensured
that ministers remained in place and
money continued to be drawn down by
departments out by departments and vital
support was provided through the UK
government's cost of living package and
there needs to be some honesty in this
place uh and and some realism well not
without its merits this place is a new
substitute for the kind of support that
can be provided through the financial
Firepower of our national government at
Westminster
in the in the months since the election
there has been a dishonesty in public
discourse emanating from some parties
they have actively cultivated and
promoted uh for cynical political
purposes a myth that there is hundreds
of millions of pounds just sitting on
the hill waiting to be handed out by a
new executive
we all know now that despite the shin
Finance Minister giving the impression
his coffers were Bountiful with cash
that he can't wait to give away if only
the dup would let him uh the executive
is hugely over budget shin fian and a
number of other parties in this chamber
have regrettably played cheap politics
with the cost of living crisis raising
false hopes and expectations no no thank
you we knew our our party our party
wants to see the institutions restored
and full we have operated them for 15
years and our commitment to demolition
is not in question
that is that is only viable however with
confidence of both not just one
community
it remains that not one unionist in this
place
it remains that not one unionist in this
place supports the protocol
just just as before the last election
not one
those I talked to in the doorsteps were
clear on our stance on the protocol when
they went to the polls they knew that
Jeffrey Donaldson had been as reasonable
as possible giving all the time and
space that he could to allow the
government to negotiate a solution or to
bring forward action of their own to
restore Northern Ireland's Place fully
within the UK internal Market
since that time on the ground I have
heard no message more lightly from the
unions community in East Belfast than
simply this stand your ground
it is not only that they understand that
the protocol is costing Northern Ireland
hundreds of millions of pounds each year
or the grace periods mask the full scale
of harm the protocol brings with it in
my experience across the union Spectrum
the people across the union Spectrum
have had enough of the foundational
tenets of the Good Friday agreement many
here are happy to install when when
convenient to themselves being
considered sacred when they are provide
when they provide political advantage or
protection to nationalism them being
discarded when inconvenient or providing
similar safeguards to unionism unionists
want the patch labeled they want furnace
restored the double standards and the
and the the double standards the
attitude of safeguards for me but not
for thee are corrosive to trust in our
institutions earlier this week we
watched as the SLP was emphasizing the
need for assembly consent in order to
block the provisions of the protocol
Bill while also wanting to override and
bend the need for Irish language
standards to be approved jointly by the
first and Deputy first ministers the
hypocrisy of these contrasting positions
is obvious and shamelessly all too
irregular nobody in this chamber today
believes this charade debate will change
anything
in the alliance party are staging
they're stunt as a Kickstart to their
campaigns in a snap election
their ground standing here will change
nothing
I I simply and genuinely say to those
who continue to dismiss the grieve
concerns of unionists on the protocol
and who demand business as usual you
Gravely underestimate the resilience and
the determination of unionists of many
Hues in this issue and your
unwillingness to hear them corroduce
confidence in our political system and
institutions power sharing requires the
the confidence of both communities
I was elected on a Monday that seeked
that I was elected on a mountain that
see seeking tangible action on the
protocol and restoring our place in the
UK internal Market I have sought to
honor that mandate and the commitments
that I have made to my electors
just as the secretary of state says he
is bound by the legislation and will do
what is required of him I am Bound by
commitments made that I give to those
who gave me my mandate and I will
continue to do what was required of me
thank you Mr Speaker
Mark Durkin
Jeremiah Lee I welcome the opportunity
to speak today to represent not only the
views of the sdlp but more importantly
to relay the police and the count the
desperation facing so many of my
constituents in the area and households
right across the north it is shameful
that it at a time of such acute need we
have been prevented from doing our jobs
affecting positive change for people
Sheltering people from the worst that
this winter will bring it is an
indelible
stay in even on the dubious record of
the dup that when people need an
executive more than ever that their
Siege of Stormwind continues and it is
starving people it is frustrating that
as members we stand here today
regurgitating yes similar please
demanding an end to yet another painful
Purgatory that achieves nothing but has
ended could change a lot
people are anxious people are angry and
justifiably so that anxiety and anger is
palpable and every parent struggling to
feed their children and every patient
waiting for care
and every family worrying about how they
will keep a roof over their family's
heads
the impact on the well-being of our
people is starkly evident we have a much
needed mental health strategy that is
largely unfunded
our communities are still reeling from
the pandemic
hit by a cost of living crisis while
caretaker ministers have largely sat on
their hands and done barely the minimum
that I am convinced of
when the own precedented challenges of
the last few years unfolded on our
Shores certainly
saying that when the reality was without
an executive without a budget the powers
of caretaker ministers were just that
caretaker ministers what we need is an
executive
remember another minute
I thank the member for the intervention
there are many ministers
who have refused in my opinion to take
action that they were able to take even
in the absence of an executive that
would ameliorate the suffering that
people here are going through
we're in the old police identity
challenges of the last few years
unfolded on our Shores there was a
collective will across Society to step
up to the plate how would our shared
Home Place have coped if the likes of
our heroic Health Force our teachers our
postal workers the housing sector and so
many more public servants refused to do
their jobs if they brought our society
to your standstill
the difference is
that if and when these beleaguered
shamefully undervalued workers aren't
paid
aren't paid when they have no
alternative but to strike
the dup do have an alternative
that said I know we want to undermine
the work that is ongoing in constituency
offices which is are busier now than
ever before the demands on office staff
and across the advice sector at this
time are evidence of the huge need out
there and highlight just how desperate
people are
every day we hear that things have never
been so bad a sentiment echoed right
across every sector from Healthcare to
housing from education to the economy
services and their workforces are
stretched beyond their limits and
elasticity that is waning and the spirit
that is set to snap ultimately my job
and the job of all of us is to change
policy and legislate to reduce the
numbers of constituents seeking our help
to create a fair and effective society
that works for everyone that's why I do
this job I know many members across the
chamber are hearing similar or the same
problems and presumably they once shared
our desire to make things better is that
not why we all got into politics in the
first place so I would ask the dup how
does it feel to be willfully making
things worse
to be making life harder not only for
the prayer not only for children not
only for the vulnerable not only for
nationalists not only for others
not only those who do not share their
Vision on a brexit they vociferously
campaigned for and on a protocol that
they know Rail and rally against
but they are making life more difficult
for everyone I don't know how they sleep
at night the hypocrisy of the dup is a
better pill to swallow when Sinn Fein
brought these institutions down for
three years in 2017 dup Representatives
told us then and have repeated during
the last session and again today how
futile and how costly that was how
irresponsible it was the blockade of our
institutions by one party is not a
democratic they aren't my words they're
Sir Jeffrey Donaldson's it begs the
question what's different now
the one and only thing that is different
now is that things are even worse the
last thing people need acting speaker
is another election which will cost
millions and change nothing I implore
those across the chamber
for the future of public services and
for the welfare of our people do the
right thing and this chaos allow us to
get on with the work that people put us
here to do
here
Peter McReynolds
thank you Mr acting speaker and I Rise
with a mixture of Pride and anger to
speak in support of nominating a speaker
today
unfortunately over the last six months
I've spent more time in this chamber
with primary and secondary schools that
I have with mlas
I haven't been able to discuss
legislation
I haven't been able to scrutinize
ministers and I certainly haven't been
able to raise issues on behalf of my
constituents on this assembly floor
like many here I was a local counselor
for five years before becoming an MLA
and I was proud to stand for election
for the alliance party in East Belfast
just six months ago
I built up a solid reputation as someone
who just got on with things and
delivered for his constituents doing the
job I was elected to do new drama no
rhetoric no time wasting
so it is Unthinkable and unconscionable
that we are here today during a cost of
living crisis a climate emergency
after a two-year Global pandemic facing
a winter that many will struggle to get
through looking at an indulgent election
to the tune of six and a half million
points at a time when many people and
families across Northern Ireland are
suffering because they're facing the
choice of heating their home or skipping
a meal
Mr acting speaker of food bank in my
constituency told me recently how
someone arrived at their door desperate
for food
they were brought to tears one offered
chilled Foods in the package they were
provided with and brought to tears
because they were ashamed to admit that
they couldn't afford the electricity to
turn their fridge on at home
children in the most deprived areas of
Northern Ireland are six times more
likely to be placed on the child
protection register and four times more
likely to be taken into care
as one food bank user wrote on their
social media recently we are a family
that is just surviving not living
what kind of society are we allowing to
exist outside these walls in 2022
food banks shouldn't have to exist we
know that
but it's especially hard for me to
stomach when some politicians sit on
their hands while it's the volunteers
who shoulder the wheel to help the most
vulnerable in our society
at the same time as all this I see and
hear how people have other people of
Northern Ireland are being used as
so-called leverage and I've heard that
screamed across this chamber today
already
misinformed by a party in this chamber
if you profess to care about Northern
Ireland them and their lives
no one
no one can tell me who the collapse of
this assembly is benefiting that it is a
constructive negotiating tactic in talks
between the UK and the EU or that it is
benefiting the communities across
Northern Ireland that put us here
they didn't elect us to go to lunches
and launches in this place we were
elected to legislate and improve the
lives of everyone in Northern Ireland
through the formation of this assembly
and an executive
not just those that voted for us not
just those that agree with us but
everyone
to turn up for them each and every
single day listen to the key workers
that we all used to clap for during the
pandemic and met the realities that they
are seeing every day easier
stories like what we heard from Dr
Julian Minnie who spoke of having to
treat children patch them up and send
them back to the environment that made
them ill in the first place or from Andy
McClanahan who broke darn as he spoke
about what he is saying and hearing from
Social Workers in his organization
those conversations took place in the
long Gallery upstairs this chamber was
silent and empty
Mr acting speaker storm and can't fix
everything that's wrong in the world
today it can't address all the issues
that we've been hearing about
but it can at least show that we care
about the people who elect us and make
the necessary changes to improve their
lives
that starts today
with getting this assembly and executive
functioning as it should
I support the election of a speaker
today I support Devolution and I support
mlas carrying out the roles that they're
elected to do
so I played with the dep I played with
my former dep counselors on Belfast City
Council
for the sake of the people of Northern
Ireland nominated speaker get this pace
up and running again and get back to
work
Justin McNulty
in Carter please in contemplating my
contribution as an selp MLA I reflected
on the Native American proverb which
proclaims
we do not inherit the Earth from our
ancestors we borrow it from our children
I'm very lucky to have three bright and
Brilliant young men from my old school
liabi and Yuri shadowing me on work
experience in this week
Ashley Hart Andrew McGinnis and Josh
Turley so Sophie King from the sacred
heart was with me last week four people
who give me a tremendous sense of hope
for the future
arshin Andrew and Josh are sitting in
the gallery today and I promised them
that I will use my time in this chamber
to voice their views
to advance their hopes and share their
fears
I asked them what needed to be said and
this is what they told me
members of this assembly have a
responsibility to represent and deliver
the people you serve were not leveraged
and should not be used as political
Pawns in a chess game where everyone
loses
regardless of whether you back Branch it
or not it's now time to back your people
not making the Democracy we depend on
holding this chamber under executive to
Ransom is holding the people to Ransom
holding families and businesses to run
some struggling with the cost of living
and cost of doing business that's out of
control
holding your own people to Ransom
holding people languishing on health
willingness to Ransom holding those
waiting for our home to Ransom
holding children with special
educational needs to Ransom
holding workers waiting for for a pay to
run some
holding us all to Ransom
the dup attraction fee for abstentious
MPS even though the dep have a
substantious ministers
attacked the dup for collapsing the
executive in 2021 even though Shin Fein
did the same for three years in 2017.
it's so disheartening for everyone to be
sidelined by their Deadlock
the question is
what are you going to do now
if mlas are seriously about making this
place work then they should get back to
work
finding a solution to the protocol will
be made so much easier if parties in
this chamber sat down together reached
an agreement and fought for for a
solution together from a position of
power in an executive
you cannot fix your past by sacrificing
our future
we want job prospects and we want
climate action
we want shelter for the homeless and
food for the hungry we want Justice and
fairness for the downtrodden and the
marginalized
we want our parents and our grandparents
looked after when they're sick
we want to view our futures with
confidence with ambition and with
excitement
from their lips to God's ears count Kona
through a combination of frustration and
despair so many of our young people opt
to build their lives somewhere other
than here
that is a very per reflection on both
the ambition and the competence of these
institutions
this latest crisis must be resolved
before the damage becomes irreversible
account Carla I have spoken here before
about the old Irish tradition of Mel
where men and women of all Creeds work
and unity to win the Harvest
through hard-toil mutual respect and
honest Endeavor communities across this
land would Safeguard one another by
spilling their sweat with each other and
for each other
my God how even a fraction of that ethos
would make a world of difference in this
place
is it too much to ask for us to come
together to spill our sweat for the
people we serve
the three young men watching you in the
chamber today have spoken very clearly
they want our shared home test to work
to thrive and to prosper
they want to look to the future with
hope and with confidence and with
excitement
they want you to do your duty and get
back to work
so
just do it
I started with the proverb and I'll
finish with one
or Scott the killer our rain nadini
people live in each other's shadows
or we rely on each other for Shelter
From The Storm
Korea
David honeyford
thank you Mr Acton speaker
I don't think an election will hasten
the day that the protocol is sorted out
but that is a matter for the government
the local parties are not at the table
to negotiate those are some of Jeffrey
Donaldson's words yesterday and we all
agree with you Jeffrey we also all agree
that your continued strike will not
hasten the day that the protocol is
sorted out either
that's a matter for the UK government
and the EU to resolve and both have
agreed to resolve the issue but from the
dep walked out last February we have
seen the steady decline in Mountain
circumstances that Ordinary People now
are living through a grown-up party of
government doesn't behave like this
it's been said about let's get real so
let's get real I want to tell you about
a family in Lagoon Valley that I dealt
with recently a typical hard-working
family like many that are in all of our
constituencies so this is Paul a
master's story from the spring
Paul works full time he earns 24 Grand a
year
an aster works part-time due to the cost
of child care so she works her hours
around her two children
they both work hard on their world and
their two kids in their home they
purchased several years ago their young
family with young children and of their
whole future ahead of them
yet Paul and Esther are really
struggling
really struggling
during covert they had no choice but to
take a holiday mortgage a holiday on
their mortgage due to furlough
and they are now paying that back
Paul drives in his job and a singers
feel cost massively increase and like
many families they now have huge
increase in their mortgage monthly
payment they are struggling to pay their
bills they Heat their homes to feed
their kids
here they were calling for help in tears
embarrassed and broken
they were out there with sand
they aren't entitled to a payment of
Universal Credit and okay they'll get
the 500 or the 400 pounds sometime when
they're electric and they'll get the
pitiful 100 pounds of oil payment but
that's such little support at a time
when they need it most
this house should be providing tailored
help for our people that is why we are
elected
Paul doesn't even know how he'll get to
work in the next few weeks
does he pay his mortgage does he put
Petrol in his car does he hate his home
or does he feed his family these are the
real choices that people are having to
make here in Northern Ireland and this
is 2022.
I often visit the local food bank in
lisburn and food banks have been
mentioned by other members already
but at this point I was for informed
recently that there was over a hundred
percent increase in this month of
October alone and to date the highest
increase was from low-income Working
Families
those are hard-working people they got
through covet and neither been broken by
this crisis
with this assembly not functioning or
been able to offer help or give
direction or stability it's working
people like Paul and Esther that you are
hurting
they are the people caught up in your
political games
in Lagoon Valley I met with the local
Pearson I
we were chatting about crime rates in
the area and I was shocked at the
Pearson I start and one that I still
can't get over again I repeat this is
2022 in lisburn stealing food to survive
from supermarkets and shops is up 53
percent this has become the highest
crime in the area
it's time to end around some politics
where the rest of us sit here partlessly
to get financial support to the very
people that need it most no one should
be left behind because these are our
neighbors they're our friends and
they're our families
shamelessly dep members have Saturday
Norton and laughing at times alone but
the elephant in the room and the
elephant in the room that I suspect the
majority of you don't even agree with
the decision your leadership has
inflicted on our people hi KJ it's
disgusting at a time like this it's
Shameless at a time like this it's
embarrassing please think of your
constituents on our constituents on
everyone's constituents call your strike
off get on with your job do the job
you're paid for and let's get this place
working thank you Mr Atkins
thank you members have no further names
on the speaking list therefore the
question is that Mr Patsy McGlone be
speaker of this assembly all those in
favor say aye
and contrary no
all those of our country say no
okay okay
[Music]
yep kill the lobbies the question we'll
put into three minutes
thank you
thank you
order members
order
order members use them your Saints
the question is that Mr Patsy mcgloan be
speaker of the assembly all those in
favor say aye
contrary if any no
members it is clear that
the uh decision has been challenged
therefore I am calling for tellers do we
have tellers
foreign
order Embers tellers have been appointed
as follows tellers for the A's Sinead
McLaughlin and Mark Durkin tell us the
nose Debra Erskine and I am
the assembly will divide eyes to my
right and nose to my left
always
foreign
okay
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
foreign
ER members who was in their seats please
order members is in their seats
the clerk will read the results
69 members voted of which 45 voted I
65.2 percent 27 Nationals voted of which
27 voted I 100
25 unionists voted of which one voted i
4 17 others voted of which 17 voted I
100 percent the motion is negative
the motion falls on fasten the doors
please
the question has not been agreed and
therefore the question will now be put
in relation to the second candidate
um I've been advised by party whips in
accordance with uh standing order 27 180
B that there's an agreement that we can
dissip that's with the three minutes
unmoved straight to the division
um
yeah the question is that uh Mr Mike
Nesbitt be speaker of this assembly all
of those in favor say
aye
contrary no
[Applause]
members as the uh whips of agreed uh to
dispense with the three minutes I now
call for tellers do we have tellers
foreign
order members uh tellers have been
appointed as followers follows tellers
for the A's Steve Aiken and Robbie
Butler tellers for the nose
Erskine and Diane Forsyth clear the
lobbies the assembly will divide eyes to
my right and nose to my left
foreign
secure the doors please
thank you
members presume their seats please
order
talk read the result
40th members voted of which 24 voted I
50 percent no Nationals voted 31
unionists voted of which seven voted I
22.6 percent 17 others voted of which 17
voted I 100 percent six members who
voted in both lobbys are not included in
these results the motion is negative
uh unfasten the doors the motion has
failed
the assembly has today been unable to
elect a speaker
and that been unable to conduct its
first item of business
therefore we can proceed no further
any further sitting of the assembly can
only be held to elect a speaker on
Deputy speakers
under section 39-2 of the Northern Iron
dark 1998 the current Speaker remains in
office until a successor is elected
I therefore by opposed by leave of the
assembly to adjourn the sitting until a
future date the details of which will be
communicated to members in due course
the question is the assembly do not
adjourn the assembly is adjourned